For this module we're still in
the Lesson1_Constants&Variables
playground file.
You've seen that the values of
constants remain well, constant, and
the values of variables can vary.
There are actually a couple of different
ways in which a constant is immutable
and a variable is mutable.
The first way has to do with
assignment and reassignment.
Once a constant has been assigned
a value, it can't be reassigned,
even when reassignment wouldn't
change the value, as in this case.
Let's take a look at this error, cannot
assign to let value, yearsOfTheGoat.
Notice that even though the values
of the yearsOfTheGoat and
yearsOfTheSheep arrays are identical,
these constants can't be reassigned.
The second way of being immutable
has to do with changing values.
If we try to change the value of the
array by appending a value to the end of
it, the compiler complains, but
for a different reason this time.
Let's take a look at this error.
Immutable value of type int only
has mutating members named append.
The problem here does not lie
with the assignment per say, but
with mutating the constant's
current value.